instead of it being called the
civil-rights in the future we're going
to have to label it a human right
struggle or the struggle for human
rights that's black nationalist leader
Malcolm X in 1964 the year before he was
assassinated during the past hour we've
had we've taken a deeper look at racism
and inequality in our special race for
justice our goal is to start a larger
conversation about how to create lasting
change CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Michelle Miller offers her reflections
on why she believes this could be the
moment that changes everything
Ferguson Missouri Sanford Florida
Charleston South Carolina cities that
are scarred what they've come to
represent safe protesters is police
misconduct for inherent bias or outright
hatred demonstrators say they want
change in how black people are perceived
in Charleston shame it seems move South
Carolinians to bring down a flag that
flew high above the cradle of
Confederacy and later other monuments of
white supremacy across the south shame
moved in weeks what years and decades
could not the systems that allowed
police brutality high rates of
incarceration and arrests greater
disparities in health care housing and
employment for blacks are much harder to
dismantle but to do that say protesters
is to acknowledge the systemic
discrimination born into the unrest of
the late 1960s I was raised in South
Central Los Angeles the product of an
interracial union then my father
celebrated and my mother to this day
does not acknowledge an early lesson for
me came from my grandmother
right or wrong she warned me to steer
clear of police officers my father a
doctor at age 22 had placed his hopes in
a senator running for
campaigned with him only to rush to his
side when an assassin's bullet felled
him
moments after he won the California
primary when busing came to California
to right the wrongs of unequal education
that little girl was me often I didn't
feel as though I fit in in those white
suburbs my first job out of college was
at the Los Angeles Times and shortly
after came the videotaped beating of
Rodney King we all became eyewitnesses
then here was evidence to decades of
claims but the acquittal of four LAPD
officers proved Society sees something
different and yet and that despair was
hoped to in a pickup game of basketball
between some neighborhood kids and four
white police officers on break from
Patrol I saw hope again in New Orleans a
few years later a city with the highest
murder rate watching first as a
journalist and then as first lady the
city found a way to root out bad cops
bad policing and cut the overall violent
crime rate by more than half
as Hurricane Katrina so ardently proved
the disparities still existed through
reporting I found the voices seeking to
be agent to change and in this instance
a movement recognizing the routing out
racism takes a lifelong commitment and
acknowledgement that its cloak of
invisibility makes it far harder to
recognize by those it does not impact
everyone must see in America who she was
and who she is
in order to decide who she wants to be
we are living with the remnants of her
original sin we must face that and bear
witness to the change that won't allow a
next time
bully Michele thank you for such a
personal piece I'm still stuck on the
earlier line in your story where you
said an interracial relationship that
your mother doesn't acknowledge does she
not acknowledge the relationship or
acknowledge you both are very painful to
hear to me no one on that side of my
family knows who I am it knows I exist
and and that's really I guess at the
core of Who I am as a journalist
acknowledgement is power and racism
impacts me to this day in that way I
probably who I married the civil rights
leader a guy who's out there fighting
every day to ensure intolerance is
overcome another this warrants another
conversation Thank You Michelle